nadège bonjour une manifestation qui a
rassemblé beaucoup demande manifestement
peur quelques milliers de personnes ont
défilé au départ de la place félix éboué
c'est quand même on peut le dire un peu
moins que lors des manifestations de la
fin
membre de la mi-décembre mais tout de
même du monde pour dire non à nouveau un
contre à la pour dire non à la loi elle
sécurité globale et son article très
controversé 1 le 24 qui est puni donc à
la diffusion malveillante de d'image t1
forces de l'ordre en rappel un an de
prison 45000 euros d'amendé alors cette
manifestation aujourd'hui à 09 dans le
calme et dans la bonne ambiance vous
allez peut-être devoir insurgés ces
images on a plusieurs centaines de
manifestants qui sont actuellement est
bien en train de fêter un peu plus tôt
de danser de chanter de profiter de
cette occasion pour faire à la fête en
cette période de confinement de crise
sanitaire
donc voilà pas deux heures particulier
plutôt une bonne ambiance même si les
esprits se sont échauffés on peut le
dire à tout à l'heure entre une poignée
de manifestants et certains membres des
forces de l'ordre puisque ces forces de
l'ordre ont été bien touché par des
boules de neige qui elle ne l'a ne leur
a visiblement pas plu quoi qu'il en soit
rien de bien méchant les esprits se sont
calmés assez rapidement je vous propose
justement d'écouter certains certains
manifestants au micro de drt france en
votant ses lois ils veulent protéger
leur arrière-garde quoi c'est à dire
tout ce qu'ils ont fait qu était
illégale et aujourd'hui veulent
légitimer par des lois donc on est
contre ces lois par exemple ben je te
donnera juste l'exemple par exemple des
drones
toi et moi dans les manifestations vous
avez pu le constater elle existe depuis
un an et demi
tout d'un coup je crois que c'est le
conseil d'état qui leur a interdit l
usage
mais en attendant l'utilisation puis un
an et demi demain s'ils votent cette loi
ça voudra dire que en fin de compte
c'était justifié de l'avoir utilisé dix
utilisaient des lois ils utilisent ils
font des choses qui sont interdites dans
les lois et donc on peut pas le tolérer
donc là ils sont en train de se couvrir
de toutes les télés les choses qui font
qu'ils sont illégales c'est pour ça
alors eux ils font des choses illégales
et après vote des lois non respecter la
loi si vous voulez que les gens prennent
en exemple ces lois justement voilà il
ya déjà cette loi sécurité globale
effectivement mais il ya aussi le
conseil d'état qui a autorisé les
services de police et de gendarmerie à
tenir des fichiers sur chacun d'entre
nous c'est à dire nos appartenances
religieuses syndicales politiques et
même voire sexuelle et ça je trouve que
c'est aberrant dans un pays comme la
france par la devise c'est quand même
liberté égalité fraternité
les ford seul du menton garde cette
devise l'a donc la loi sécurité globale
couplé avec ça c'est complètement
liberticides et donc effectivement il
faut pousser le gouvernement à abroger à
cet or ce seuil ce projet de loi qu'ils
ont on ne peut pas laisser ça à nos
enfants c'est pato sied à une
manifestation à qui elle continue qui se
court ce lien dans la bonne humeur alors
qu'un important dispositif
sécurité entourent cette place de la
bastille vous allez le voir un sur ces
images plusieurs centaines de membres
des forces de l'ordre en quatre sets 6-7
manifestation que le camion cannes
hoarau est également placée au cas où
alors pour l'instant pas de sommation
des portes de l'ordre un pont demandé
aux aux manifestants de quitter la place
il peut manifester en europe un moment
mais voilà en tout cas les forces de
l'ordre sont prêtes et dont celle - et à
passer à l'action et pilleurs ou peugeot
6 1 6 1
s'il est 6e aucun heurt n'a éclaté
aujourd'hui serre on peut dire ça peut
s'expliquer par cette importante
présence policière qui a lieu
aujourd'hui
merci à nos jeunes pour à toutes ces
précisions